do the protests and riots have a stated
end goal
i guess it's just abolished the usa you
say quote the police should enforce the
law and i agree but how exactly
what tactics would you use arrest
everyone every night tear gas disperse
money to go home yeah it's a great
question and
in fact it's one that i want to ask some
of the people who are protesting i want
to ask that
uh to the people who are most most
capable of answering it
good but let's say this
the nature of a riot is that there is a
failure
of the ability to enforce the law based
on
the immediacy the suddenness the fact of
the force being overwhelmed right the
same thing that creates looting
is that you have a force built for
normal circumstances when something
abnormal of sufficient
magnitude arises the force is not
adequate to do it
two months into a reliable riot that's
not where you
are whatever resources need to be
brought to bear
on two blocks of portland is it possible
to bring a force
large enough to deal with law breakers
in two blocks of portland of course it
is
so the fact that we're not doing it is
not because it's impossible to figure
out what those tactics might be
it's that there's no will to do it and
the no will to do it at the local level
forces the feds to defend their
buildings
which is then being portrayed as a
fascist incursion etc and so you know
look it's theater it's theater with uh
you know
weapons with weapons and so weaponized
theater let's just not pretend that it's
something else
this is a failure of the local which is
leaving the federal as the
last line of defense and it shouldn't
surprise anybody that there's some level
of
federal enforcement to protect these
buildings that's where we are
yeah and just to speak briefly to the
first question
in this question do the protests or
riots have a stated end goal
i haven't heard it you know we've seen
things like abolish usa and
um you know and defund the police which
in some people's minds means and the
police
but i will relay an anecdote that nancy
roman
uh who lived here in portland for 15
years and just moved away
last year but is back at the moment
reporting for reason
in one of her one of her missives that
is now published at reason
about what is going on here on the
ground in portland she reports just
a conversation with a young just a
slight
girl really like a young woman uh who
probably weighs less than 100 pounds
who's sort of on the front lines um at
the
at the federal building as they as the
protesters are trying to get in this is
well after midnight and
uh nancy hears her ask somewhat
plaintively
what happens if we get in
and and no one answers right and
um this i think is is telling that um
if there is a stated end goal it's not
shared by even all the people who are
participating
um and by which i don't mean they don't
all agree but
most of them don't even know it so uh
i would say the movement has an end goal
and it is the capture and wielding of
power
over resources that is where it will
cash out
for sure right the local phenomenon
does not the goal is happening the goal
is the ability to portray what is taking
place as a fascist incursion into
portland
um that the new york times will
dutifully report as such
and this is that state we've gotten
there yeah